- [Voiceover] So, in the last video,
I introduced the vector form of
the multivariable chain rule
and just to remind ourselves,
I'm saying you have
some kind of function f,
and in this case I said it comes from
a 100 dimensional space,
so you might imagine--
Well, I can't imagine a
100 dimensional space,
but in principle, you're just thinking
of some area that's 100 dimensions,
it can be two if you wanted to think
more concretely in two dimensions.
And it's a scalar valued function
so it just outputs to a number line,
some kind of number line that I'll think
of as f as its output.
And what we're gonna do is we compose it
with a vector valued function
so some function that
takes in a single number t
and then outputs into that
super high dimensional space.
So you're thinking, you go
from the single variable t
to some very high dimensional space
that we think of as full of vectors,
and then you take from that
over to a single variable,
over to a number.
And you know, the way you'd write that out
is you'd say f composed
with the output of v,
so f composed with v of t,
and what we're interested in
doing is taking its derivative.
So the derivative of that composition is--
and I told you and we
kind of walked through
where this come from, the gradient of f,
evaluated at v of t, evaluated
at your original output,
that product, with the derivative of v,
the vectorized derivative,
and what that means, you know,
for v, you're just taking the
derivative of every component.
So when you take this and
you take the derivative
with respect to t, all that means is
that each component, you're
taking the derivative of it.
The x1 dt, the x2 dt, on and on until d
and then the one hundredth component dt.
So this was the vectorized form
of the multivariable chain rule.
And what I wanna do here is show
how this looks a lot like
a directional derivative.
And if you haven't watched the video
on the directional derivative,
maybe go back, take a look,
kind of remind yourself, but in principle,
you say, if you're in
the input space of f,
and you nudge yourself
along some kind of vector v,
and maybe just because I'm using v there,
I'll instead say some kind of vector w.
So not a function, just a vector.
And you're wondering, hey,
how much does that result
in a change to the output of f,
that's answered by the
directional derivative
and you'd write directional derivative
in the direction of w of f,
the directional derivative of f,
and I should say at some
point, some input point,
p for that input point and
it's a vector in this case,
like a 100 dimensional vector.
And the way you evaluate it,
is you take the gradient of f,
this is why we use the nabla
notation in the first place,
it's an indicative of how we compute it,
the gradient of f evaluated
at that same input point,
the same input vector p.
So here, just to be clear,
you'd be thinking of
whatever vector to your
input point, that's p.
But then the nudge, the nudge away
from that input point is w.
And you take the dot product
between that and the vector itself,
the vector that represents
your nudge direction.
But that looks a lot like
the multivariable chain rule up here,
except instead of w, you're
taking the derivative,
the vector value derivative of v,
so this whole thing you could say
is the directional derivative
in the direction of
the derivative of t, and
that's kind of confusing.
Directional derivative in the
direction of a derivative,
of f, and what point are you taking this,
at what point are you taking
this directional derivative?
Well, it's wherever the output of v is.
So this is very compact,
it's saying quite a bit here.
But a way that you could
be thinking about this,
is v of t, so I'm gonna
kind of erase here.
V of t has you zooming all about
and as you shift t, it kind of moves you
through this space in some way.
And each one of these output points here
represents the vector,
v of t at some point,
the derivative of that, what
does this derivative represent?
That's the tangent vector to that motion,
you know, so you're zipping
about through that space,
the tangent vector to your motion,
that's how we interpret v prime of t,
the derivative of v with respect to t.
I mean why should that make sense?
Why should the directional derivative
in the direction of v prime of t,
this change to the
intermediary function v,
have anything to do with the
multivariable chain rule?
Well, remember what
we're asking when we say
dt of this composition is we're saying
we take a tiny nudge to t,
so that tiny change here,
in the value t, and we're wondering
what changed that result
in after the composition?
Well, at a given point,
that tiny nudge in t
causes a change in the
direction of v prime of t.
That's kind of the whole meaning
of this vector value derivative.
You change t by a little bit,
and that's gonna tell you
how you move in the output space.
But then you say, "Okay,
so I've moved a little bit
"in this intermediary
100 dimensional space,
"how does that influence the output of f
"based on the behavior of just
"the multivariable function f?"
Well, that's what the
directional derivative is asking.
It says you take a nudge in
the direction of some vector,
in this case, I wrote
v prime of t over here.
More generally, you
could say any vector w,
you take a nudge in that direction.
And more importantly, you know,
the size of v prime of t matters here.
If you're moving really
quickly, you would expect
that change to be larger, so the fact
that v prime of t would
be larger is helpful.
And the directional
derivative is telling you
the size of the change in f as a ratio
of the proportion of
that directional vector
that you went along. Right?
You could--another notation
for the directional derivative
is to say partial f, and then partial
whatever that vector is.
Basically saying you
take size of that nudge
along that vector as a
proportion of the vector itself,
and then you consider
the change to the output
and you're taking the ratio.
So I think this is a very
beautiful way of understanding
the multivariable chain rule.
Cause it give this image of, you know,
you're thinking of v of
t, and you're thinking
of zipping along in some way,
and the direction and
value of your velocity
as you zip along is what determines
the change in the output
of the function f.
So hopefully, that helps
give a better understanding
both of the directional derivative
and of the multivariable chain rule.
It's one of those nice
little interpretations.